as you can imagine most of the year
sevens and a handful of your rates who
have signed up to this are the students
who have self-identified and said look
I'm a struggling student I'm a person
who doesn't really get it and it's the
person like I tried to mimic to you
before someone who really knows I need
some help with this okay so in some ways
your goal is a tutor is couched in terms
of that like where they've come from
their own self concept I'm a struggle so
your main role in that way negatively
speaking is to make them not struggle
anymore or at least to be comfortable
with their struggle to say okay I don't
get it immediately but I'm all right
with that I'm confident enough now I've
sure been shown you know I don't know if
you guys remember what it's like if you
were to try and do something and just to
get it wrong repeatedly it's incredibly
discouraging so a huge part of your role
is not just like the academic stuff but
can you emotionally support someone so
you can get up again and give it another
go that's the negative side we don't
want them to be so antagonistic and and
struggling with this subject however
this is what the other side of the piece
of paper is for we also once you have a
positive goal like I'm not just working
towards not something I'm not just
working towards getting rid of something
I want to replace it with something
positive and what that is is this I
really expect that most of you have seen
this before it's from the syllabus
document that all of your learning from
for the last well it's k 2 10 so that
makes it 11 years this represents I know
you can't see it all too well in terms
of the details but this rep says one
three not intended for vanity one two
three major areas all mathematics that
you like that we call them strands right
you've got number and algebra you guys
know what that is measurement and
geometry stuff like volume surface area
and so on and then over here in the
corner you've got statistics and
probability again something you're from
the movie okay now what you see going
out in those sectors that are color are
all of the different topics so on 2d
space mass volume and capacity patterns
and algebra fractions and decimals
things that you'll be familiar with as
the titles of chapters and textbooks
that you've worked through okay however
that's not what I enjoy your attention
to I want you to look at the middle bed
right now if you squint really hard or
if you look at the piece of paper in
front of you there are five the kind of
like burbs I suppose there are five
verbs that are not content they're not
like ideas or concepts that you learn
they are skilled their ways of thinking
and we call them working mathematically
ok this is the positive image that we're
working towards it so I really want to
quickly give you a sort of nutshell idea
of what is it like what is your picture
for what you want your tutee to end up
with it the end of the year you want
them to you and do one two three four
five things ok so turns in that table
with me we're going to go through them
one at a time the first one is
communicated now each of these words is
a word that is borrowed from everyday
language but we have a really specific
meaning in a mathematical context for
what communicating means so here's my
definition you can have a look at that
first little empty spot communicating
this is as simply as I can put it is
expressing an idea it's expressing an
idea in a way that others can see you
say that again communicating is
expressing an idea
in a way that others can see it is no
good expressing all these kinds of ideas
and no one it's all gibberish this on us
you're not communicating that's what
you're doing communicating is now be
able to take an idea or a picture of
something and be able to put it as
someone else's mind now why is that
important some of these are easier than
up I've got a sentence that i've crafted
for you that I want you to fill in for
me right here's why communicating is
important it is so important and it's
why it's the first one I've mentioned
communicating is important is because an
idea is more powerful when it can be
shared let's say out again and idea is
more powerful when it can be shared if
you have an idea that's nice but you're
never going to start a revolution or
change the society if you're the only
one who has that idea okay but if
there's a common movement all these
people who have the same ID all the same
time you can move a culture so no you in
illustration for that right in fact he's
methylation sheehan like water we're not
here we go now the whole idea of doing
like still life like this right is that
a guy is standing over there but you
want to be able to communicate visually
something onto a piece of paper so that
if someone doesn't see this anymore and
all they've got is your communication
they'll be able to recognize this idea
in the future and that's why we play
such an important emphasis on working
out on diagrams on chart all these kinds
of things they are all mathematical
forms of this of communicating putting
an idea from your hair into someone
else's I don't think about it this way
it's kind of like telepathy through
paper okay now second idea coming after
this who's problem solving okay so we're
looking at a second runner what is
problem solving here's my description of
what problem solving is from solving is
knowing and not just knowing but picking
effective strategies for working through
your problems it's two things knowing
and picking effective strategies for
working through problems
knowing appear the effective strategies
for working through problems now why is
it matter why is it important that's
because hopefully you guys feel
mathematics is interesting you know but
math mathematics elegant but it's not
just is my third column mathematics is
not just interesting and elegant it is
also useful and effective you can do
things with it you can put all of those
fractions or decimals a percentage of
what it is you can put it in a context
and you can solve a problem with it so
mathematics is not just interesting and
elegant it's useful and it's effective
okay so here is my imageries right what
promise of a looks like is can you take
good from pay to be if Castle Towers is
in fact where you want to go right now
skills are one thing being able to turn
the wheel to the left brake indicate but
applying it to an actual problem that's
problem solving getting from somewhere
you don't know how to get there or you
put to get all your skills in your mouth
at apart okay that's what problem
solving means in a mathematical context
let's move on number three reasoning ok
reasoning is is simple we do lots of
reasoning whenever we do proof reasoning
is here we go using logic using logic to
argue for something being true or false
using logic tough I cube for something
being true or false that's one reason
why is reasoning important reason is
important because here's my arm why it
matters is because reasoning is the way
mathematicians it's how we make progress
we actually advance through tell him it
progress mathematicians take things we
already know and build on them
mathematicians take things we already
know and we build on and that's at every
class
geometric proofs starts right here's a
shape you know like one or two themes
and using reason using logic you can
draw a conclusion which is exactly what
sort or loses this is a crime scene
right forensic investigators they take
clues they use logic they use deduction
right and then they can prove they can
reason by means of these things to
arrive at a conclusion say something is
true something is false something one is
guilty someone is innocent that is what
we are doing every time we construct
approve every time you risen almost
there and tell her understanding
understanding you might think while
understanding has been obvious right
like it isn't that what everything is
about there is something specific
understanding is seeing and using
connections between ideas connections is
the real kick right understanding is
seeing and using connections between
ideas now why does it matter why does it
matter to be able to understand
something well if you've ever been even
use something before but not really
understand how it worked you don't
really get to use the most effective
sort of news on that item so when you
actually get something this is my third
polymer when you actually get how
something works you then actually see
through it to other problems and here's
my illustration so my kids are two five
and seven years old okay and so they
know what I remote control is and no one
remote control is they know how to press
buttons on it but they do not understand
how it works so when they pick one up
they don't understand why when they're
in another room they're mashing the
buttons furiously and nothing's
happening what is it they're failing to
understand about a remote control what
is it
you have to point it like this like this
little infrared me and then when you
point at it you have to be close enough
and it has to be nothing in the way it
works if you understand you can see
through to understand what's really
going on ok that's understanding seeing
the connection lastly what is not oh
that's right foods what's fluency me
this is the last of the working that
getting into it fluency is working with
tools and methods here's the key quickly
and accurately it's working with tools
quickly and accurately the reason why it
matters is because it enables efficiency
like you don't need to think about tying
your shoelaces or brushing your TM it
just happens right because you are
fluent at you develop that skill right
it enables efficiency and it frees up
the mind to think critically to actually
think critically about what you're doing
rather than being focused on bunny is
left goes under loop up what I done okay
and here's an example here's my
illustration right you are all fluent in
English you don't have to work out like
my five-year-old son does wait which
later is that again hold on okay great
I've got my own pages with Oh got it
right eh right what's the next one let's
go through every single what is not
fluent yet so therefore he can't
understand what this means I like the
way you can because you are fluent in a
language and the same thing happens
formats right we are fluent in skills
and once you a fluent with those you can
build on the mini other places
communicating problem-solving reasoning
understanding and fluency these are what
you're trying to build for your tootsie
okay